un wc le messin voilà ok pour la
télévision et le médecin est en baisse
pour la télévision
c'est bien ce que nous avons entendu
jacques donc médecin a baissé ok pour la
télévision la réponse de houston c'est
le premier geste que doit faire amstrong
lorsqu'il descend tirait sur une poignée
qui se trouve sur la plateforme
ce qui provoque l'ouverture de la case
où se trouvent les équipements les
outils et la caméra décoller armstrong
vient de procéder à la dernière fois la
version du site
l'image est à l'envers
on demande aux retournements l'âge
position de la caméra retournement de
l'image voilà le pied armstrong au
centre et en bas de votre écran
ils descendent en base du lem pas du
pied
le plus important maintenant est la
grande crainte que l'on avait eu 6 à 12
tonnes c'était que l'astronaute ils
sortent le même ton pour le plus
important c'est qu'on pouvait leur
stabilité
jalbert maintenant nous écoutons
instants apparemment la surface et d'un
grain de sable très fin 10ème temps
voici le premier pas
à
et je descende l'échelle maintenant dit
armstrong
je me tâte le sol du bout de l'orteil
dit armstrong
le sol est très ferme
je ne peux pas voir l'empreinte de mon
pied sur le sol le sol qu'il compare
d'ailleurs une poussière de charbon et
ils marchent maintenant